les chiffres de la construction pour
2018 sont connus ils sont mauvais - 7 %
viennent de paraître
les chiffres du nombre de logements
sociaux financés en 2018
ils ne sont pas mauvais monsieur le
ministre ils sont très mauvais avec -20
% en ile-de-france - 20 % en deux ans et
-20% en retrait par rapport à l'objectif
de 2018
bien évidemment tout le monde s'inquiète
pour 2019 car il n'y a aucune chance que
la situation s'améliore alors ça
pénalise bien évidemment les français
qui attendent un logement social mais ça
va aussi pénalisé les communes
auxquelles au titre de l'article 55 de
la loi sru
on fixe des objectifs de construction de
logements sociaux
en 2015 le cgedd organisme d'état avait
déjà tiré la sonnette en disant qu'en
2019 les deux tiers des communes
risquait d'être carences et parce que
les objectifs assignés était trop
important combiné à cette crise du
logement social que vous avez créé par
vos choix politiques
vous allez mettre beaucoup de communes
dans une très grande difficulté alors
monsieur le ministre quel instruction le
gouvernement entend t-il données aux
préfets de région qui préside le comité
régional de l'habitat pour que cette
difficulté soient prises en compte au
moment où sera jugée la bonne volonté
les maires pour construire du logement
social
mercher
pour vous répondre la parole c'est au
ministre chargé de la ville et du
logement cheminée j'avais la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président d'allier vous évoquez les
chiffres de la construction dans le
domaine du logement social
on vient de les avoir vous l'avais dit à
l'échelle du territoire national en 2018
on a engagé à peu près 100 9000
logements contre 113 mille l'année
précédente et leurs référentiels que
vous donner c'est un référentiel sur
l'année 2016 en ile-de-france qui était
une année exceptionnelle
je crois que vous le savez très bien et
que cette année là de manière de manière
générale en ile de france c'est moins 3%
par rapport à l'année dernière mais
c'est à peu près le même niveau que
l'année 2015
ça c'est la réalité des chiffres qu'on a
mais vraiment et je crois qu'on se
connaît suffisamment je ne suis
absolument pas là pour soi faire de
l'angélisme soit dire que les chiffres
sont bons aujourd'hui nous n'avons
absolument pas suffisamment de logements
sociaux
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire face à
ça il ya au moins deux choses qu'il nous
faut faire à très court terme
la première c'est de faire en sorte
qu'on lève les incertitudes les
inquiétudes qui aujourd'hui perdure au
sein du mouvement des logements sociaux
c'est notamment toute la démarche de la
clause de revoyure que nous avons
engagées à laquelle vous avez participé
monsieur le président d'alliés pour
qu'on puisse trouver les solutions
notamment vis-à-vis des inquiétudes de
l'année 2020 que nous connaissons bien
la deuxième chose c'est de mettre en
oeuvre la réforme que nous avons porté
dans le cadre de la loi est lent et j'en
veux pour preuve juste un élément vous
savez on a beaucoup poussé et certains
dans ces bandes poussé également pour un
certain nombre de regroupements au
moment où je vous parle il ya 3 140
structures de logements sociaux qui sont
concernés par les regroupements
il y en a à peu près de 230 qui ont
entamé ces procédures de regroupement
dont quasiment les deux tiers qui sont
très avancées déjà dans un projet ou
bien avancé et ça il faut continuer à y
aller et à y aller avec détermination
enfin le dernier point que vous évoquez
c'est sur les carences est sérieux vous
connaissez très bien le système et je
prends bonne note de ce que vous avez
donné
vous savez très bien que effectivement
il y à une appréciation des préfets qui
sont donnés dans le cadre des carences
et notamment dans le cadre de l'atteinte
des objectifs
triennal qui est fixé à chaque fois j'ai
pris bonne note de votre recommandation
monsieur le sénateur lieu le président
10 au moins sur le constat nous devrions
pouvoir tomber d'accord il y a l'urgence
pour le logement social
ici au sénat des républicains au parti
communiste tout le monde à l'automne
2017 et à l'automne 2010 8 vous a dit
que vos décisions allaient précipiter le
secteur dans une crise nous y sommes
nous y sommes alors il serait fort de
café monsieur le ministre que les
communes auxquelles vous avez a signé la
loi sinde objectif de construction
paient les pots cassés de la politique
que vous avez décidé de conduire
monsieur le ministre
regarder la réalité en face et prenez
les bonnes décisions merci